[Music]  it's morning again in America today more  women will go to work than ever before  in our country's history this year  dozens of children will be born to happy  and healthy families it's morning again  it's morning together  wake up America mornings over  I was asleep before that's how we let it  happen when they slaughtered Congress we  didn't wake up when they blame  terrorists and suspended the  Constitution we didn't wake up then  either  now I'm a week you girls will serve the  leaders and their barren lives you will  bear children for them there's an I in  your house  I want to keep on living for her  not let him cry to tell you straight  they should have never given us uniforms  if they didn't want us to be an army  [Music]  you